bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo bienvenue sur les
chaînes parlementaires à mes côtés
céline bittner bonjour s'est dit bonjour
mickaël esnault l'actus cette semaine
après le choc des attentats le
gouvernement était attendu sur les
propositions des annonces des moyens et
des hommes l'arsenal anti terroriste a
été renforcée l'armée parvient à sauver
des postes mobilisation également pour
l'école l'accent est mis sur la laïcité
au total plusieurs centaines de millions
d'euros seront engagés dans ce contexte
les français apprécient l'action du
couple exécutif un bond historique pour
françois hollande qui retrouve des
sommets à temps avant son élection de
2012 manuel valls gagne lui aussi des
points à gauche comme à droite et plus
cette semaine le président de la
république s'est adressé aux
parlementaires et il a lancé son plan
pour la transparence de la vie publique
transparence pour les élus pour la vie
économique plus de règles plus de
vérification 1 pour commenter cette
semaine notre invité est david rachline
bonjour alors vous êtes un peu un
symbole un symbole car vous êtes l'un
des deux premiers sénateurs de
l'histoire du front national plus jeune
sénateur de la vème république à 27 ans
vous représente également cette nouvelle
génération frontiste voulue par marine
le pen
et puis vous êtes aussi un petit peu
cumulards puisque vous êtes également le
maire de la ville de fréjus
alors je voudrais qu'on regarde ensemble
cette image regardez c'était le 1er
octobre 2014
votre premier jour au palais du
luxembourg et en tant que benjamin vous
étiez secrétaire de séance plusieurs
sénateurs ont alors refusé de vous
serrer la main
est-ce que ça se passe mieux aujourd'hui
écouter les choses se passent très bien
j'étais pas de toute façon venu au sénat
pour me faire des amis je suis là pour
défendre des grands électeurs qui m'ont
fait confiance qui ont fait confiance à
mon mouvement et qui considérait qu'il
était logique somme toute que plusieurs
millions d'électeurs soit représenté au
sénat nous ne sommes que deux d'ailleurs
je pense que
ce n'est pas le reflet de ce que nous
représentons réellement mais il n'en
reste pas moins que depuis les choses se
passent bien on vous sert là bas dans
les couloirs oui absolument la plupart
et reste toujours quelques secteurs mais
peu importe je suis pas là pour leur
plaire donc ça ne me dérange pas là vous
connaissez le principe de l'émission va
passer en revue tout ce qui s'est passé
cette semaine dans l'actualité va
commencer par le lundi françois hollande
et manuel valls ont la cote c'est un
bond de popularité record pour
l'exécutif 21 points pour le chef de
l'état 17 points pour manuel valls il
récolte en fait les fruits de la gestion
de la crise qui vient de se dérouler
jean baptiste daoulas le rebond est
spectaculaire d'après un sondage ifop
fiducial pour paris match la cote de
satisfaction de françois hollande gagne
21 points à 40% le président de la
république n'avait pas atteint un tel
niveau de popularité depuis février 2013
regain de confiance également pour
manuel valls +17 points
le premier ministre est à 61 % de bonnes
opinions
un rebond lié à la gestion des attentats
terroristes de charlie hebdo et de la
porte de vincennes clairement les
français considèrent que françois on a
été à la hauteur qu'il a réussi à gommer
les critiques récurrentes en termes de
manque d'autorité en termes de manque de
fermeté en termes d'atermoiements c'est
maintenant un président qui incarne
union fois nationale et qui a mis fin
aux landes bashing parce que ce qui a
absolument nouveau dans ce sondage c'est
bien sûr la progression de françois
hollande à gauche en gagne 30 points
chez les sympathisants socialistes
mais c'est aussi et surtout pour la
première fois il progresse nettement ses
sympathisants de droite et du centre la
séquence est délicate pour l'opposition
difficile de critiquer françois hollande
après deux semaines d'union nationale
toutes les bulles spéculatives ont
vocation un jour exploser donc nous
verrons quand nous reviendrons dans une
période un peu plus classique j'allais
dire où les français regardons l'heure
ces jus lors leur sujet de préoccupation
quotidienne tels que l'évolution du
chômage l'évolution de la situation
économique et sociale de notre pays
en 1991 un françois mitterrand avait
connu également un rebond au début de la
guerre du golfe
mais cette lune de miel avec l'opinion
n'avait duré que quelques mois
david rachline cette question va
peut-être vous surprendre mais faites
vous partie de ces français qui ont
changé de regard sur le public
en tout cas on peut dire que il est
quand même normal que les français se
solidarise de leur gouvernement
en pareille situation et il est vrai
nous l'avons dit d'ailleurs clairement
que françois hollande a plutôt bien géré
ces moments éminemment douloureux pour
notre pays néanmoins désormais il va
falloir laisser passer le temps du deuil
est maintenant se concentrer sur les
véritables propositions dans notre pays
a besoin pour pouvoir prévenir ces
menaces ramat on va y venir
j'imagine haute pour françois hollande
et manuel valls oui dans le cadre de la
gestion encore une fois de ce drame dans
le cadre de l'hommage qui a été rendu je
crois à l'exception de l'exclusion du
front national marine le pen de la
fameuse marche
il n'en reste pas moins que globalement
je considère qu'il est normal que les
français se rassemblent autour de notre
pays de son gouvernement autour de la
république française et de ces valeurs
vous ne regrettez pas de ne pas avoir
participé à voir nous allons tous vers
mais nous a dit venez vienne qu'il veut
mais nous avons participé aux marches
dans la paroisse il n'y a pas que paris
est aussi moi j'étais à fréjus avec plus
de 5000 fréjusiens sur la place de la
ville sur la place de la mairie
tous les ans la grande photo denis tous
les dirigeants tous les dirigeants du
cac à paris
tous les dirigeants du front national
était partout dans les provinces de
notre pays
je crois que on ne va pas à une
manifestation dans laquelle nous ne
sommes pas invités je pense que c'est
somme toute logique et je regrette qu'à
cette occasion le gouvernement a exclu
25% des français en tout cas une
responsable politique majeur qui
n'aurait pas dû être exclu de mon point
de vue l'une des seules quand même
personnalité politique qui n'augmentent
pas qui stagne dans les sondages c'est
marine le pen alors pourtant sur le fond
à la période là pourrait sembler propice
aux thèses du front national pourquoi ça
ne profite pas votre parti vous savez
nous étions encore une fois dans la
période du deuil dans la période de
l'hommage et c'était bien normal
viens aujourd'hui le temps de la
réflexion des propositions le pen s'est
exprimée s'est exprimée seulement il ya
quelques jours vendredi dernier je crois
à l'occasion d'une grande conférence
non je crois pas du tout encore une fois
à vendredi dernier elle a commencé à
s'exprimer sur les propositions qu'ils
étaient moins qui sont les nôtres et
dont on va avoir l'occasion probablement
de reparler
et je crois que c'est là dessus que nous
allons être jugé je ne me fais pas de
souci je vous signale au passage qu'ils
aient eu un sondage dans le figaro il y
à quelques heures pour dire que 45% des
français et le pouvaient éventuellement
voter pour le front national donc nous
ne sommes pas si isolé que ça le gros
test pour l'exécutif pour vous pour tout
le monde finalement le parti politique
c'est quoi c'est la prochaine
législative partielle qui aura lieu dans
le doubs c'est là dessus qu'on va juger
si l'exécutif a réussi vous savez les
législatives partielles réagissent aussi
en fonction de considérations locales et
je crois pas qu'il faille se concentrer
là dessus en revanche la professeure de
test national pour la prochainement
devant nous en tirons un certain nombre
de conséquences bien sûr mais ça n'est
pas l'alpha et l'oméga de ce qu'il faut
considérer politiquement aujourd'hui en
revanche la prochaine élection
importante majeur c'est les élections
départementales qui vont avoir lieu en
même temps au niveau national et là nous
verrons véritablement où on l opinion et
je crois qu'on peut s'attendre à de très
bons résultats pour notre mouvement bien
sûr alors ce lundi c'est aussi la colère
de plusieurs pays musulmans contre la
une de charlie hebdo à gaza en iran
tchétchénie ou encore on a gagné ce
temps des milliers de manifestants ont
protesté contre la une de l'hebdomadaire
satirique représentant le prophète
mahomet des drapeaux français ont été
brûlés au pack us pakistan à niamey au
niger des français ont été invités à ne
pas sortir de chez eux après des
manifestations violentes
elle reste que charlie hebdo a bien fait
de publier nouvelle fois la caricature
de mahomet à la une ou alors est-ce que
c'était une provocation
vous savez je crois que notre république
notre pays est attaché à la liberté
d'expression et à ce titre charlie hebdo
publié ce qu'il lui plaît et ce qu'il a
envie de publier néanmoins effectivement
ça a suscité un certain nombre de
réactions je crois que par certains
aspects le centre
excessive mais nous ne pouvons pas
demander à tous les pays du monde
d'avoir les mêmes pratiques que nous
d'avoir le même ton dans les médias dans
la presse d'avoir cette même liberté
d'expression ce serait mieux si c'était
le cas ça n'est pas le cas nous devons
en prendre acte de simplement
mais faire respecter en tout cas en
france ce principe clair de liberté
d'expression qui m'apparaît essentiel de
cent mille personnes en tchétchénie ça
vous a surpris ou pas oui on doit
l'avouer
oui c'est beaucoup indéniablement et je
crois que les gouvernements de ces pays
serait bien inspiré de rappeler qu' il
faut respecter les autres nations moins
du monde respecter la france pour ce
qu'elle est je pense que certains un
point important est ce que ce n'est pas
aussi le symbole finalement d'une montée
d'un sentiment anti français
c'est surtout la démonstration
manifestement d'une montée d'une forme
de radicalité dans la pratique des
religions et je crois que par certains
aspects nous pouvons nous en inquiéter
nous voyons ce développement faramineux
de l'islamisme radical en série par
exemple en irak aussi mais pas seulement
au yémen et ailleurs et je crois qu'il
faut que là aussi nous en tirions un
certain nombre de conclusions et surtout
que nous protégions notre pays contre
ces menaces des rivaux mardi manuel
valls emploie des mots qui fâchent
c'est une formule choc lors de ses voeux
à la presse le premier ministre a
dénoncé un apartheid territoriale
sociale ethnique pour des cas la
situation des banlieues
une petite phrase qui a fait une bien
sûr beaucoup réagir rinne benameur près
de deux semaines après les attentats du
7 janvier comment lutter contre la
division de la société française comment
rebâtir une unité nationale manuel valls
lors de ses voeux à la presse dresse un
lourd constat oui c'est les jours on
soulignait beaucoup des maux qui rongent
notre pays ou des défis que nous avons à
relever la relégation périurbaines les
ghettos ce que j'évoquais en 2005 déjà
un appart hyde territoriale sociale
ethnique
quelques heures plus tard le premier
ministre répond à françois de rugy lors
des questions au gouvernement
avec la même gravité dire que pour ce
qui concerne l'école où les quartiers où
le sentiment de relégation ou de ses
négations dire qu'il faudrait résoudre
ces questions en quelques jours en
quelques semaines n'aurait aucun sens
nous répondrons d'ailleurs pas à
l'exigence des français aux quatre
colonnes le mode apart est utilisé par
manuel valls divise
si on prend le mot apartheid pour ce qui
veut dire c'est à dire un développement
séparé des gens au sein d'une même
communauté nationale
c'est en partie ce qui est en cours en
france la politique d'apartheid en
afrique du sud c'était une politique qui
visait à séparer les gens leur interdire
de l'orme à toutes sortes de barrières
dans la progression dans la société
c'est parce qu'a voulu la république
française françois hollande a chargé les
deux assemblées de réfléchir aux moyens
de renforcer l'appartenance républicaine
notamment grâce au développement du
service civique
les deux chambres ont jusqu'au mois de
mars pour faire des propositions de dire
des choses fortes pour être entendu
c'est un peu la méthode que vous aussi
vous pratiquez au front national
oui en choisissant les termes que nous
employons et surtout moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le fond des choses
qu'est ce qui fait que nous en sommes
arrivés en effet par certains aspects
une séparation
on a parcouru noter vous reprendrez ce
monde ne reprendrait pas ce terme de on
peut parler en revanche de séparation
dans un certain nombre de cas entre les
populations on peut parler de
communautarisme et qu'est ce qui fait
que nous en sommes arrivés là c'est la
politique appliquée par l'ump et le ps
depuis maintenant des dizaines d'années
ce sont eux qui ont malheureusement
amener ses revendications communautaires
à être exaucé ce sont eux qui ont
produit cette situation et je crois que
on ne peut pas général à part du premier
ministre vous a choqué le mot
d'apartheid
il est assez il est assez choquant mais
ce qui est encore plus choquant encore
une fois c'est de voir manuel valls
aujourd'hui dénoncer une situation qu'il
a avec ses amis ump et ps d'ailleurs lui
même créée et je crois que c'est cela
dont il faut parler mais alors vous même
chaque gardé un petit peu les chiffres
mais dans votre ville de fréjus vous
avez réduit
les subventions aux associations est ce
que ça ça ne provoque pas de fête une
ghettoïsation des quartiers dont vous
savez à fréjus j'ai simplement fait en
sorte que les centres sociaux
fonctionnent mieux et en effet 7 50% à
les subventions pour les centres nous
avons mis fin à un certain nombre de
dépenses inutiles et nous avons fermé
même un centre social pour créer à la
place une maison de quartier qu'israël
grâce au service jeunesse de la ville
grâce au ccs beaucoup plus à même de
traiter les différents problèmes qui se
posent à ce quartier mais de manière
générale je crois que avant toute chose
et avant toutes problématiques liées aux
centres sociaux et la question sociale
il faut rappeler un certain nombre de
valeurs clair que sont l'autorité la
discipline et l'ordre public qui est le
combat contre le communautarisme et je
crois que ce sont des valeurs qui
malheureusement n'ont pas suffisamment
été rappelé par le gouvernement et par
l'état ces derniers mois et ces
dernières une proposition de malek
boutih qu'on a vu dans le reportage
c'est la mise sous tutelle de l'état de
certains quartiers où seriez peau non
non non je ne suis pas pour la mise sous
tutelle d'un certain nombre de quartiers
je crois que les administrations locales
et les collectivités territoriales
doivent se gérer parce qu'ils sont élus
pour le faire les maires dans la plupart
des cas sont à la hauteur de la
responsabilité qu'est ce que quel que
soit d'ailleurs leur étiquette politique
ce n'est pas la question
il essaye avec des moyens toujours moins
importants à cause des économies
budgétaires qui sont faits justement par
l'état sur le dos des collectivités
territoriales de gérer la situation
qu'est ce que vous proposez concrètement
alors pour éviter justement cette
ghettoïsation
vous savez il faut lutter contre le
communautarisme de manière ferme dès le
plus jeune âge et je crois que ça c'est
éminemment important il faudra aussi
lutter contre le communautarisme c'est
rappeler les valeurs de la république
c'est ne pas céder aux revendications
communautaires c'est ne pas permettre de
piscine par exemple par exemple
les menus dans les cantines et tout ce
dont on n'a pas l'habitude de parler
depuis maintenant des années les burqas
qu'on a le droit manifestement en tout
cas de fête d'été loire de continuer à
il ya un certain nombre de lois mais
dans les foyers revenir soit que ça
n'est pas appliqué et donc c'est le
respect total de la laïcité encore une
fois ça n'est pas suffisamment le cas
aujourd'hui et je crois que l'ump et le
ps est particulièrement ce gouvernement
porte une responsabilité majeure dans
l'absence de respect de la laïcité dame
auguste d'amo sur le mot apartheid qui a
été prononcée est ce que la manuel valls
a brisé l'unité nationale qui étaient en
cours mais de toute façon il est normal
que les débats dans une démocratie dans
la république reprennent mais l'unité
nationale n'aurait peut-être pas dû être
brisé de cette manière là avec ce mot là
un visage a fait la une de l'actualité
ce mardi celui de el hassan a bâti lit
ce jeune malien de 24 ans est devenu
officiellement français cet employé de
l'épicerie père cacher avait aidé des
clients à se dissimuler dans la chambre
froide lors de la prise d'otage de la
porte de vincennes manuel valls et
bernard cazeneuve le ministre de
l'intérieur a salué son acte de bravoure
vous qui êtes contre l'immigration est
ce que lassana bâti dit c'est pas la
preuve que l'immigration peut aussi être
une chance pour la france
vous savez moi je suis pour le contrôle
aux frontières d'abord et pour réduire
en effet drastiquement le nombre
d'étrangers qui rentre sur notre sol car
il en rentre encore 200 mille par an je
crois que c'est beaucoup trop et que ce
n'est pas d'ailleurs sans lien avec la
situation de communautarisme qui se
développe dans notre pays mais dans ce
cas bien précis il est bien évident que
et est d'ailleurs moi je crois que
l'année de la nationalité s'hérite ou se
mérite
en ne tolérant en l'occurrence il la
mérite et c'est bien normal qu il qu'il
puisse devenir français mais ça ne doit
pas être automatique comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on devrait être
beaucoup plus raisonnable dans le nombre
de
de l'acquisition de la nationale 6 110
personnes pour un tract en 2014 ce qui
est beaucoup moins ce qui est beaucoup
trop toujours pas ce que vous savez nous
n'avons plus les moyens de cette
politique nous n'avons plus les moyens
d'accepter l'arrivée sur notre
territoire de 200 mille immigrés de
chaque année je crois que la
démonstration en est faite que tous les
politiques s'accordent à dire que
l'immigration est trop importante dans
notre pays
mais l'ump comme le ps n'en tire pas les
conclusions et ne régule pas aux
frontières
cette immigration la saison nous avons
là en effet un vrai sujet ce contrôle
aux frontières qu'il va falloir rétablir
dans les plus brefs délais hawaï venir
justement sur les mesures contre le
terrorisme qui ont été prises par manuel
valls nous sommes mercredi 15 jours
après évidemment les attentats qui ont
ensanglanté paris les mesures étaient
attendues manuel valls a annoncé un
renforcement considérable des moyens
humains et matériels
un plan d'urgence pour lutter contre le
djihadisme de détail avec marie frémeau
c'est un gouvernement uni derrière son
premier ministre qui est venu présenter
l'ensemble des mesures pour lutter
contre le terrorisme
un gouvernement uni est entièrement
mobilisé pour ce faire des moyens
importants sont débloqués ce sont 420 5
millions de crédits d'investissement
d'équipement de fonctionnement qui
seront consacrés au cours des trois
prochaines années
ce plan de renforcement 425 millions
d'euros donc sur trois ans pour
surveiller près de 3000 personnes
impliquées de près ou de loin dans des
filières terroristes
une enveloppe budgétaire qui permettra
notamment de gonfler les effectifs de
renseignement 1400 emplois rien que pour
le ministère de l'intérieur
mais les effectifs seront également
renforcés à la défense bercy et à la
justice d'ailleurs dans le cadre de la
lutte contre la radicalisation 60
millions d'euros seront mobilisés et 60
au money
musulmans seront recrutés pour les
prisons un fichier placée sous le
contrôle d'un juge sera fait dans lequel
seront obligatoirement inscrire toutes
les personnes condamnées ou juge herman
mises en cause pour des faits le thé
rose
c'est donc un fichier spécial de
personnes condamnées pour terrorisme qui
va voir le jour afin de permettre leur
surveillance quant à la peine
d'indignité nationale qui fait débat le
premier ministre n'a pas tranché il a
dit ne pas vouloir agir dans la
précipitation et a confié aux deux
assemblées le soin de formuler des
propositions complémentaires
est ce que les mesures annoncées par
manuel valls sont suffisantes pour
lutter contre la menace t aurais bien
sûr que non et la véritable question est
pourquoi ont-ils supprimer des postes de
policiers et de gendarmes dans les dix
dernières années pourquoi les moyens des
renseignements ne sont pas à la hauteur
ne sont plus à la hauteur de la
situation
c'est pourquoi avons-nous fait des
économies sur les moyens de l'armée
depuis maintenant plusieurs dizaines
d'années je crois que c'est ça la
véritable question est évidemment qu'il
nous faut renforcer les moyens de la
police et de la gendarmerie dans les
proportions considérables évidemment
qu'il faut renforcer les moyens de
l'armée et pas seulement faire cesser la
baisse des moyens renforcés les moyens
de l'armée qui est dans une situation
aujourd'hui
osram hattrick ou est ce que vous faites
les économies des centaines de milliers
d'euros d'économies à faire rouler on
pourra en rediscuter sur l'immigration
sur l'union européenne sur toute une
série de sujets vous savez que dans ce
domaine là les propositions en tout cas
de notre côté ne manquent pas mais il y
a d un certain nombre d'éléments sur
lesquels on ne peut pas transiger et je
crois que malheureusement pendant de
trop nombreuses années des économies ont
été faites sur ces postes là ça n'aurait
jamais dû être le cas maintenant
d'urgence il faut renforcer les moyens
je le disais de la police du
renseignement de l'armée parce que nous
le voyons bien c'est indispensable
est-ce que sur le fond vous serez
d'accord avec un patriot act à la
française
bon c'est pas exactement ce qu'on y met
à l'intérieur ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
va falloir renforcer dans des
proportions considérables non seulement
les moyens que je viens d'évoquer
mais encore agir sur l'éducation agir
sur la justice pour lutter contre le
récidiviste mais j'ai posé en ce sens
une question
la garde des sceaux qui vient de qui
avait supprimé récemment des mesures
contre les récidivistes alors que au
contraire pas encore pas encore mais
j'espère que j'espère que j'en aurai une
bientôt dans tous les domaines il nous
faut il nous faudra agir
malheureusement c'est le laxisme qui a
triomphé que ce soit dans l'éducation
dans la justice c'est le laxisme qui a
triomphé dans tous les domaines trop
d'angélisme bien sûr et pas de prise de
conscience de la réalité de la situation
pas de prise de conscience du
développement ou que nous avons dû les
dénoncer de ce fondamentalisme islamique
qui se propage dans un certain nombre de
nos quartiers et dans un certain nombre
de nos villes ça ne veut pas dire que
tous les musulmans évidemment sont de
dangereux citoyens mais une petite
partie font la démonstration qu'ils sont
dangereux et nous devons mettre tous les
moyens pour lutter contre ça n'a pas été
le cas jusque là malheureusement alors
que nous nous avions prévenu alors losio
la dignité déchéance de nationalité y
avoir ni calendrier le conseil
constitutionnel se prononcer ce vendredi
sur la nationalité d'un franco marocain
condamné pour terrorisme déchéance de
nationalité validée par le conseil
constitutionnel est une bonne nouvelle
bien sûr qu'il faut déchoir de leur
nationalité
ceux qui commettent des actes graves et
même ceux qui sont des délinquants
récidivistes et même toute une série de
gens qui n'ont pas être sur notre
territoire
je crois que c'est la pure logique nous
devons choisir ce qu'il peut le faire
que quand il ya la double nationalité
conseil constitue d'ailleurs bien voulu
aller plus loin vous en tout cas on est
si déjà on faisait cela ce serait déjà
pas mal
et si déjà ceux qui ont la double
nationalité de toute façon nous nous
sommes contre la double nationalité et
nous croyons qu'il faut choisir et qu'on
ne peut pas que ce principe de double
nationalité n'est pas n'est pas sérieux
mais pour ceux qui aujourd'hui ont la
double nationalité bien sûr qu'ils
doivent être déçus c'est une évidence
absolue
eh bien il faut prévoir un renforcement
du dispositif judiciaire des peines
qu'ils soient plus importantes
aujourd'hui quand on a cantonné à donner
et national par exemple
peu importe les mots mais aujourd'hui
sachez que lorsque on est condamné à une
peine de moins d'un an de prison on ne
la fait pas parce qu'on manque de place
dans les prisons parce que notre
dispositif carcéral et judiciaire n'est
pas à la hauteur de la situation
je crois que dans ces domaines là il va
nous falloir travailler sérieusement et
en tout cas il faudrait que ce
gouvernement
le fasse sur le plan militaire
maintenant françois hollande a tenu un
conseil de défense ce mercredi l'armée a
réussi à sauver des emplois 7500 postes
de militaires seront finalement épargné
sur les trente-quatre mille supprimés
est ce que là mais a encore les moyens
de ses ambitions et les moyens de
défendre
finalement notre pays entre les
opérations extérieures est aujourd'hui
le plan vigipirate renforcé bien sûr que
non et nombre de responsables de l'armée
se sont exprimés à différentes occasions
et ont tiré la sonnette d'alarmé nous
mêmes depuis des années deux mois au
sénat j'ai eu l'occasion d'intervenir
sur le projet de loi de finances dans
ces domaines là et nous voyons bien que
non seulement les moyens ne sont pas à
la hauteur mais qu'en plus ils étaient
drastiquement réduit ces dernières
années alors qu'au contraire il eût
fallu les augmenter ou en tout cas les
maintenir moi je crois que il faut que
les moyens soient renforcés qu'il faut
que l'état fasse un véritable effort
dans ce domaine là parce que nous ne
pouvons pas en même temps essayer de
dire et de rassurer les français sur
leur sécurité sur la situation
notre pays nous en demandons toujours
plus à l'armée alors qu'ils ont toujours
des moyens qui sont très courtes la loi
sur le renseignement qui est prévue pour
mars ou la vôtre et ou pas écoutez nous
verrons ce que nous voterons nous irons
dans le détail pour vérifier si si les
moyens sont à la hauteur de la situation
ce qui est sûr c'est que je suis
partisan d'un renforcement très
important les moyens et nous aurons
l'occasion de faire un certain nombre de
propositions y compris au sénat
d'ailleurs service civique ou service
militaire vis militaire obligatoire
service militaire service militaire pour
2,3 pour quelques mois
mais évidemment que cette cette
suppression n'est pas allé dans le bon
sens et c'est indispensable
jeudi c'est l'école qui est en première
ligne
là il s'était auto rités citoyenneté
trois mots qui résument le plan de la
jat vallaud belkacem pour réaffirmer les
valeurs républicaines à l'école 250
millions d'euros seront investis sur
trois ans les détails avec marie prévost
on a laissé l'école la communauté
scolaire les enseignants devenir le
réceptacle de tous les maux de la
société
alors qu'elle devrait son protégé pour
protéger chaque élève un constat d'échec
mais la volonté de rectifier le tir
la ministre de l'éducation a présenté
les grandes lignes de son plan pour
remettre les valeurs républicaines au
centre de l'école ce sont 1000 formateur
aguerris qui seront formés sur la
laïcité et l'enseignement moral et
civique avant la prochaine rentrée
scolaire
mille inspecteurs professeur
documentaliste ou chefs d'établissements
qui seront formés pour répondre aux
questions relatives à la citoyenneté la
laïcité et à la lutte contre les
préjugés
une journée de la laïcité sera désormais
célébrée dans tous les établissements
chaque 9 décembre journée anniversaire
de la loi de séparation des églises et
de l'état
tous les établissements devront
également participer aux commémorations
patriotiques et mettre en place de
nouveaux rendez vous la semaine de
l'engagement et la semaine de la lutte
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme
tout comportement contraire à ses règles
fera l'objet d'un signalement
systématique de la part de l'enseignant
au directeur d'école ou chefs
d'établissement et ces derniers seront
invités à y donner suite
systématiquement
voilà donc le volet sanction de ce plan
qui veut également asseoir l'autorité
des professeurs
l'exécutif souhaite un recours plus
systématique aux mesures de réparation
et de responsabilisation sortes de
travaux d'intérêts généraux pour les
élèves toutes ces mesures s'inscrivent
dans le cadre d'un nouveau parcours
citoyen du cp à la terminale
au total 300 heures d'enseignement moral
et civique mais également aux médias et
à l'information des mesures
consensuelles qui ont un coût de 150
millions d'euros
trois ans est ce que c'est le bon moyen
de réaffirmer la laïcité à l'école où il
faudrait aller encore plus loin il faut
aller plus loin
évidemment et je crois que c'est dès le
plus jeune âge qu'il faut lutter contre
les communautarismes et nous nous avons
dix pour démontrer cela qu'il fallait
rétablir l'uniforme à l'école
nous avons dit aussi qu'il était c'est
une bonne proposition bien entendu les
signalements dont on parle qui vont être
c'est au rectorat
ça n'est pas suffisant il faut convoquer
les parents systématiquement il faut
signaler sa au procureur de la
république pas au recteur même si ça
n'est pas incompatible fer de kehl faut
des mesures il faut des mesures mais dès
le plus jeune âge
dès le plus jeune âge dès lors que les
enfants sont à l'école et qu'on voit
qu'il ya un certain nombre de dérives il
faut des signalements qui soient des
signalements opérant qui puisse
permettre une réaction de la part de
l'autorité publique de la part de la
justice éventuellement à l'égard de
l'enfant bien sûr mais l'égard des
parents quand c'est pour les très jeunes
je crois que c'est très important
on n'en fera pas l'économie et
malheureusement je crois qu'on ne va pas
assez loin
aujourd'hui dans ces domaines là donc un
manque d'autorité selon vous aujourd'hui
de la part il faut aussi réapprendre dès
le plus jeune âge l'éducation civique il
faut aussi peut-être un petit peu de
morale à l'école
aujourd'hui on sait que là une partie en
tout cas des enfants sortent de l'école
sans savoir parler le français
et c'est absolument dramatique il faut
donc renforcer dès lors du tour de
france et les parents aussi plus selon
vous oui mais bien sûr bien sûr qu'il
faut le responsabiliser les parents je
vous en parlais à l'instant et je vous
disais que le signalement doit être
frais auprès le probablement du
procureur de la république pour qu'il
puisse agir sur sur les parents et pas
seulement sur les enfants puisque ce
sont les parents aussi qui sont chargés
qu'aux charges et de leur éducation et
ses dérives naissent aussi en partie à
cause d'un certain nombre de parents qui
sont défaillants il faut bien dire
j'avais de la laïcité le 9 décembre
parce que vous veillerez à ce qu'elle
soit célébrée dans votre ville à fréjus
mais moi je respecte les lois de la
république
évidemment et elle vous plaît et lorsque
ce sera voté puisque ce sera
probablement le cas alors comme partout
en france la loi de la république sera
respectée évidemment inbev qu'elle vous
plaît peut-être leur bord
et peut-être même d'abord dans ma
commune c'est à dire écoutez moi je suis
favorable à ce que dans ma commune les
lois de la république soit respectée
on imagine donc peut-être d'abord et
avant tout donc vous verrez également à
ce que la laïcité soit toutes les lois
autour de la laïcité soit mise en place
oui johnny leurs neuf parce qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui je pense à
l'interdiction du voile des signes
religieux
vous savez la question des mères voilées
pour les sorties scolaires bien sûr
comment est-ce que vous appliquez ça
chez vous bien sûr mais nous sommes
vigilants ne rencontre pas nous
rencontrons pas particulièrement de
problématiques liées à cela
à fréjus en tout cas mais je sais que
nombre de maires sont confrontés à ces
situations c'est plutôt difficile il
faut que j'aie envie or l'état soit aux
côtés des collectivités locales aux
côtés des élus locaux pour leur apporter
une aide pour pouvoir traiter ce
problème parce que ce n'est pas le maire
d'une petite commune seule sans moyens
qui est capable de répondre à cette à
ces problématiques donc il faut là
encore que l'état accompagne les
collectivités pour faire respecter la
loi et je crois que là encore le
signalement et j'en termine dès des
instituteurs et des directeurs d'école
est très important ils doivent
participer agir aux côtés des élus
locaux la sphère cahuzac était nous sont
passés par là françois hollande veut une
république plus transparents encadrement
des nominations contrôler des lobbys et
le chef de l'état a lancé une série de
mesures pour renforcer la déontologie
dans la vie publique
on écoute françois hollande pour éviter
que des manquements ne soient connus
postérieurement à l'entrée en fonction
des intéressés il devra être procédé à
des vérifications avant tout les
nominations des plus importantes
je sais aussi que les assemblées
travaille sur des propositions par
rapport aux candidatures aux élections
ensuite les nouvelles règles
déontologiques seront étendues à tous
les acteurs publics fonctionnaires comme
magistrat des projets de loi seront
déposées au parlement et seront bientôt
inscrit à l'ordre du jour enfin il
faudra encore rendre plus claires là que
fout confection des lois et des
règlements pour un meilleur encadrement
des groupes de pression les loin se
multiplient pour renforcer la
transparence dans la vie publique et
pourtant dans l'impression en tout cas
français ont l'impression c'est un petit
peu un voeu pieux est ce que la
république exemplaire voulue par
françois hollande c'est pour maintenant
c'est surtout un peu tard parce que
après le nombre d'affaires qui sait il
faut bien le dire multiplier depuis ces
derniers mois particulièrement au parti
socialiste et ça ne sont pas les seuls
d'ailleurs puisque d'autres sont apparus
au grand jour particulièrement à l'ump
je crois que c'était nécessaire et donc
évidemment qu'il faut aller vers
davantage de transparence est une
évidence absolue mais il ya aussi à
faire dans le choix des hommes et les
mouvements politiques y compris leur
direction devrait peut-être être
davantage vigilants sur les gens qu'ils
choisissent pour aller représenter la
question parce qu'au front national
aussi l'arrivée par des affaires avec
des avec des élus lesquels par exemple
vous savez c'est normal que vous n'ayez
pas honte elle est extrêmement rare
contrairement à l'ump est la différence
d'ailleurs que nous avons d'ailleurs là
la différence d'ailleurs que nous
lorsqu'il y a une problématique avec un
élu nous nous en séparent ont
immédiatement ça n'est pas toujours le
cas du parti socialiste qui pendant des
mois à garder monsieur qu'elsa que comme
ministre me semble-t-il
il en est de même pour tous les élus qui
ont été condamnés à différentes
occasions madame andrieux était encore
récemment vice présidente du conseil
régional en connivence qui a préparé le
plus vite possible de la personne qui a
comme une fois lors il faut envoyer un
message clair il faut que les parties
prennent les responsabilités qu'ils
écartent les brebis galeuses si on peut
dire
et encore une fois il ya un vrai travail
à faire dans le choix des hommes et des
femmes qui nous représente et qui sont
les représentants de la république alors
j'ai regardé un j'ai cherché sur le site
internet du sénat
votre déclaration de patrimoine n'a pas
encore été publié vous venez d'arriver
mais est-ce que vous pensez que voilà
c'est ce genre de d'exemple ou de
procédures qui peuvent aller dans la
bonne voie ce coup vous êtes prêt à aix
à nous dire par exemple l'état de votre
peau patrimoine aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau
oui oui mais vous savez à 27 ans à 27
ans il est quasiment inexistante
la vérité donc par conséquent j'ai pas
du tout de problème avec ça j'ai envoyé
évidemment le document en question qui
sera publiée je pense dans les prochains
jours dans les prochains mois c'est pas
moi qui ai qui gère ça mais moi j'ai pas
du tout de difficulté avec ça et je
pense que chacun peut publier son
patrimoine si ça vous paraît
indispensable mais le véritable problème
c'est de savoir si on s'enrichit grâce
au mandat qui est le nôtre c'est ça le
vrai problème et je pense que c'est là
dessus que nous devrions agir en tout
cas avoir des vues allez on en vient
tout de suite à notre nouvelle rubrique
de parlement hebdo c'est la loupe du
scan avec notre partenaire du figaro le
scan point fr nous accueille le
rédacteur au chef de ce site jaime jara
c'est jim carrey lecture encore très
chargé cette semaine décryptées
bonjour david raffine c'est mon le
sénateur frontiste que l'ex responsable
de la communication numérique du front
national que je vais interroger
aujourd'hui je vais essayer de devoirs
avec vous quelle est la commande à la
communication numérique du front
national a évolué et notamment ces
dernières semaines on a l'impression que
c'est devenu plus compliqué de gérer
toutes les expressions numérique des
cadres du front national j'ai plus leur
exemple
le premier c'est ce tweet de jean marie
le pen qui a été publié le 9 janvier il
faut rappeler le contexte c'est le jour
du double assaut à dammartin-en-goële et
sur la porte de vincennes à l'épicerie
cacher il ya ce tweet qui sort sur le
twitter de jean marie le pen qui calment
voc le pen gardez votre calme
votez le pen c'est une fin flagrant
délit de récupération politique
est ce que vous regrettez ce type de
tweets devrait d'abord moi je suis pas
jean marie le pen donc vous poserai la
question à jean marie le pen moi je vais
vous dire que oui ça c'est un fait mais
ce que je peux vous dire en tout cas
c'est que notre stratégie sur internet
et la stratégie que nous avions mises en
place dès l'élection présidentielle en
2012 a fonctionné nous sommes les
premiers est le premier parti politique
sur internet
nous avons une efficacité record dans ce
domaine là
et nous n'avons pas de difficultés
majeures en l'occurrence ce tweet est ce
qu'il était dans une ligne de
communication consciente du front
national quelque chose de volontaire la
ligne de communication et qui a été la
nôtre c'est celle qui a été développé
par marine le pen pendant pendant ces
semaines c'est semaine difficile pour
notre pays
jean marie le pen à sa liberté de ton il
est un il est habitué à en user
d'ailleurs il faut bien le dire et c'est
sa responsabilité mais ce qui est ce qui
est certain c'est que la ligne du
mouvement politique la ligne stratégique
l'orientation clair c'est marine le pen
qui la fixe et je crois qu'elle est
l'occasion de le faire et c'était
parfaitement clair autre exemple alors
autre exemple cette vidéo de
l'eurodéputé aymeric chauprade dont on
parle beaucoup cette semaine et on va
regarder quelques extraits tout de suite
on nous dit qu'une majorité de musulmans
et pacifique
certes mais une majorité d'allemands
l'été avant 1933 et le national
socialisme allemand
une majorité de russes de chinois de
khmers étaient pacifiques avant qu'il ne
réalise d' abominables crimes au nom du
communisme
marine le pen s'est désolidarisé
d'aymeric chauprade en l'interdisant
carte du front national de diffuser
cette vidéo pourtant marion maréchal-le
pen s'est fendu d'un petit tweet pour
diffuser cette vidéo alors on a
l'impression qu'il ya deux camps un peu
qui se dessine sein du front national
dans quel camp vous situez vous mais
pour commenter le tweet de tel
responsable policier national
ça promet encore garanti que cette
semaine la réalité c'est la suivante
marine le pen a été élue avec 100 % des
voix au dernier congrès c'est elle qui
fixe la ligne c'est elle qui fixe le cap
politique du front national elle a eu
l'occasion de dire qu'elle était en
désaccord avec une partie en tout cas de
la vision d'aymeric chauprade
les choses sont donc éminemment clair le
front national sa ligne a été rappelé
par la présidente et une seule ligne et
il n'y a qu'une seule ligne au front
national c'est extrêmement clair
moi je suis en l'occurrence sur la liste
du front national seulement à sa place
au front national aujourd'hui mais
encore une fois les c'est à lui de nous
dire si je crois d'ailleurs pouvoir dire
que à 95% il est d'accord avec la ligne
de marine le pen et avec la ligne
stratégique politique qui est celle de
notre présidente
il faut encore une fois un petit peu de
discipline dans un mouvement il faut
respecter une forme d'autorité on en
parlait tout à l'heure mais dans un
parti politique c'est valable aussi et
donc il est normal que marine le pen
remette de l'ordre quand c'est
nécessaire
une polémique a également éclaté un dans
votre ville de fréjus que vous avez pris
la décision en décembre je crois de
supprimer l'abonnement de la médiathèque
à plusieurs quotidiens nationaux dont
libération et le figaro alors vous
invoquez des choix budgétaires c'est
c'est tout à fait compréhensible et vous
avez le droit en tant que maire de 2,9
de faire ça non mais vous opposants
locaux ont organisé une manifestation
pour dénoncer une atteinte au pluralisme
de la presse mais est ce que vous n'avez
pas regretter cette décision après les
attendant on frappait la rédaction de
charlie mais vous savez d'ailleurs bon
hein les adversaires politiques du parti
socialiste qui étaient présents ce jour
là étaient 10 et l'immense majorité des
fréjusiens a bien compris que c'était
pas le maire de fréjus qu'avait fait ce
choix il y avait un budget acquisition
journaux de 11000 euros il est passé à
7000 euros dans le cadre des économies
j'ai désendetter la commune qui était la
cinquième commune la plus endettée de
france 2 8 millions et demi d'euros sur
la première année il ya beaucoup de
collectivités
peut-être qu'ils feraient bien de s'en
inspirer on est passés donc 260 160
abonnement à sans abonnement pour une
raison simple c'est qu'il nous fallait
faire des économies encore une fois et
donc la direction de la bibliothèque a
choisi les
les journaux les magazines qui était là
lui condamné vous remettez le figaro
breveté libe c'est ceux qui sont les
plus consultés qu'ils ont été conservés
maintenant encore une fois ci ça fait
plaisir au parti socialiste ou si ça
fait plaisir un certain nombre de
personnes
s'il faut remettre le figaro pour leur
faire plaisir moi je suis une bonne
composition dont et mais nous verrons
encore une fois mais si les fréjusiens
le réclame vous savez ils peuvent aussi
les gens du parti socialiste qui allez
lire libération et pas spécialement le
figaro je pense ils peuvent aussi aller
dans un kiosque
et puis ce qu'ils ont des indemnités
d'élue importante au madame di méo et je
crois présidente de commission au
conseil régional elle a des indemnités
importantes et peut aller soutenir la
grèce
en allant acheter dans un kiosque ou
même en s'abonnant ce qui se voulait la
porte ouverte merci vous dirigez la gym
portes ouvertes
voyez une des conséquences évidemment ce
qui m'a très lourd c'est les films qui
ont été déprogrammés ces derniers jours
par des mères vous êtes maire on vous
demandera votre avis dans un instant
c'est le plus de l'hebdo pour l'un de
ses films l'histoire raconte sa
conversion d'un jeune français de
tradition musulmane au catholicisme pour
l'autre l'arrivée des islamistes à
tombouctou
deux films qui ont été déprogrammés dans
certaines villes s'est racontée par
simon barbarie ce qu'il touche c'est
jésus christ fils de dieu
un jeune musulman qui se convertit au
christianisme le sujet est sensible
c'est celui du film l'apôtre réalisé et
produit par cheyenne caron un mini
budget 50000 euros
une diffusion plus que discrète moins de
dix salles en france
et pourtant la direction générale de la
sécurité intérieure a vivement conseillé
la déprogrammation du film dans une
salle de cinéma nantaise un risque
d'attentât et évoqué la projection est
annulée que c'est une juste de jésus qui
est il pour toi vraiment même message à
un cinéma de neuilly sur seine mais
cette fois ci la projection est reportée
à la mi avril
des précautions compréhensible mais en
contradiction avec les nombreux messages
sur la liberté d'expression distillées
dans la sphère publique
depuis des attentats de charlie bien
loin de la provocation l'apôtre est un
film foncièrement pacifistes ou peu à
peu catholiques et musulmans avance vers
une compréhension mutuelle timbuktu
d'abderrahmane sissako a lui aussi été
déprogrammé à villiers sur marne
le maire ump jacques alain benisti un
cru que le film sélectionné au dernier
festival de cannes faisait l'apologie du
terrorisme
peut-être aurait-il dû voir l'oeuvre
avant car elle en est tout le contraire
tout beau tout neuf à un rétropédalage
du maire s'en est suivie le film sera
finalement projeté dans une quinzaine de
jours mais escorté d'un débat avec
responsables religieux et associatifs
des précautions qu'il ya quelques
semaines encore aurait semblé bien
superflue vous voulez maire de fréjus
seriez vous prêt à céder à des
intimidations pour déprogrammer un film
non clairement non je pense qu'il est
important que la liberté d'expression
soit totale est compris dans le monde
cinématographique
non moi je peux comprendre l'inquiétude
d'un élu local qui considère que les
conditions de sécurité ne sont pas
réunies
et donc voilà c'est un sujet un petit
peu compliqué mais là le rappel et
éclaire sur la valeur qu'est la liberté
d'expression liberté d'expression un
petit peu à géométrie variable au sein
du front national puisque vous même vous
avez interdit un journaliste de
l'express d'accéder à une vo conférence
de presse à fréjus le petit journal est
interdite des congrès frontiste c'est
pas quand même deux poids deux mesures
non non pas du tout dans la l'immense
majorité de nos réunions tous les
journalistes sont les bienvenus et vous
le savez bien vous en interdisaient
certains vous êtes seul parti politique
à tout d'abord le petit journal sont pas
des journalistes
c'est du divertissement
et quand on voit si vous voulez la
manière qu'ils ont de nous traiter
je crois que en effet ça n'est pas
acceptable quant à par exemple mediapart
que nous refusons aussi et ce sont eux
qui avaient choisi de ne pas traiter
marine le pen dans le cadre de la
présidentielle donc c'est un juste
retour de l'enfant merci de
la chine va pas recommencer avec la
mention l actualité de la semaine merci
michael est très bonne suite des
programmes